the Hawaiian Islands are like heaven on
Earth
but in 2019
Paradise is in peril
a terrifying creature emerges from the
depths
and carries out an eerie series of
attacks
filling mystery must be solved before
it's too late
we're on the island of Oahu this island
represents a lot of history to Open
Water Swimming Eric Shaw is a long
distance swimmer who specializes in a
discipline known as Channel swimming
Channel swimming is swimming from one
Island typically to another Island
through a large body of water
it's like swimming a marathon
I met a guy named Steve and he told me
about this swim called the kaiwi Channel
as being part of ocean 7.
Ocean's 7 is a challenge created in 2008
enticing long-distance swimmers to
tackle some of the most dangerous Waters
in the world
the Molokai Channel also known as the
kaiwi channel located between the
Hawaiian Islands of Molokai and Oahu is
one of the ocean's seven challenges
stretching approximately 26 miles across
plunging 2300 feet it's known for its
treacherous currents and abundant sea
life
few people have ever made it across
we all know that you're going to have
rough water lots of wind and sharks
the Hawaiian Islands are home to roughly
40 different species of sharks including
the Galapagos shark that hugs the
coastline
the sandbar shark that feasts on reef
fish squid and octopus
and the Mako known for its Speed and
Agility
these Predators rarely trouble swimmers
but they're not the only ones who roam
these depths I knew that white sharks
and tiger sharks would be a possibility
and that our crew to a notify us if
there was a a large predatory shark
knowing that I had a great sense of ease
and confidence in in their ability to
get us from Malachi to Oahu
but out in the open ocean an unseen
Terror that no one anticipated lies in
weight
this is the first time I've been back
yeah there's a lot of emotions going on
right now
[Music]
we started our swim at 6 20 in the
evening the sun was setting
we had a kayaker in the water who was
following the boat and we're swimming at
night we're following the the most
minimal amount of lighting possible
which was for us red glow sticks
as we were swimming through the dark
every time our hand would enter the
water I noticed an amount of
bioluminescence that I had never
witnessed or experienced previously
bioluminescent phytoplankton our
microscopic organisms that light up when
water is disrupted
about four hours into the swim
Steve was hit by a Portuguese man of war
and when he was hit he pulled up pretty
quickly and let out a pretty good Yelp
Steve had to call it and that was uh the
turning point of the swim
I had been swimming for about an hour or
so by myself
and then I encountered a sensation in my
abdomen a sensation of burning and my
hand came down across my abdomen
but I could sense that something was not
right
and so I swam over to the kayaker and I
remember him immediately getting on his
marine radio and said shark
crewman Francesco Forte Springs into
action we quickly realized something was
wrong when we saw Eric grab the kayak
because once they touch it they know
that their swim is disqualified distant
swimmers they will do everything they
can in their power to avoid touching
that kayak that was actually the one who
pulled him out of the water and I pulled
them back and placed them down onto the
deck of the boat and I looked down at
his wound my first thought was just like
okay when you apply pressure because
this is a huge huge injury
and if we lose Blood by the time we get
to shore there's not much we can do
radio for help and rush back to shore
there an ambulance transports Eric to
the hospital I was taken right back to
an operating room immediately
and that's when I discovered that I had
a good three and a half inch diameter
hole in my abdomen that was a good inch
and a half deep
it takes 26 Staples to close the wounds
Eric's recovery is long and arduous took
me a good year until I was able to stand
up straight again
Eric's chilling encounter makes
headlines around the world
shark attacks in the Molokai channel are
extremely rare in the previous 100 years
there have only been seven recorded
attacks but in 2019 the attack on Eric
is just the beginning three weeks later
a second swimmer is attacked in the same
stretch of water
and a few months later a third shark
bite stuns the Hawaiian Islands
the cause is a mystery
locals are desperate for an answer to
the unprecedented surge in attacks
three happening in one year we thought
you know there must be something going
on I really want to get to the bottom of
this because I want to know that I can
continue to play in this ocean me and
everybody else is curious to know why
there was that spike in 2019 and then
none since then
in an attempt to uncover what's behind
the attacks investigators first turn
their attention to the species of shock
involved
and suspicion immediately falls on two
notorious sharks that inhabit Hawaiian
Waters
I knew that white sharks and tiger
sharks would be a possibility
white sharks
are the ocean's largest predatory fish
they can grow up to 20 feet and are
responsible for more fatal attacks on
humans than any other shark
tiger sharks named for the striped
markings that Adorn their flanks dubbed
the garbage cans of the sea they will
eat anything from sea turtles to tractor
tires
a surprising detail emerges from Eric's
account that suggests a very different
shark was involved I encountered a
sensation in my abdomen a sensation of
burning and my hand came down and I
grabbed onto a fish
while the crew was watching for larger
sharks could something smaller have gone
undetected
Dr Dan Huber of the University of Tampa
examines Eric's unusual bite wound the
lower part of the wound is very very
circular you can see here from the depth
of this wound that it went through
multiple muscle layers got really deep
caused a lot of tissue damage
this circular pattern Bears all the
Hallmarks of one of the strangest and
rarely seen sharks in the ocean these
have those telltale signs of a cookie
cutter shark having been involved in the
attack
named for the circular wounds they leave
on a victim's flesh cookie cutter sharks
spend most of their time in the deep
ocean
each night they migrate to the surface
where they are believed to feed on large
fish and marine mammals
although they only grow to about two
feet in length they have a
disproportionately large mouth compared
to their body size
and a set of Jaws filled with razor
sharp teeth and what they do is they
latch onto their prey and suck onto it
with these fleshy lips and then dig that
lower jaw into that prey item
to demonstrate how devastating a cookie
cutter shark bite can be Dr Huber has a
3D printed set of cookie cutter Jaws
when cookie cutter sharks bite onto
their prey first it attaches the upper
jaw and then it sinks the teeth from its
lower jaw into that prey item and then
they do one of two things either they
just scoop through the prey item and
excavate a big chunk of Flesh or
sometimes they dig that lower jaw in and
then start twisting their body around
the long axis and carve out a perfectly
circular chunk of Flesh from their prey
items and that's not all when Dr Huber
examines bite marks on the other two
victims he makes a shocking Discovery if
you look at the shape of that plug this
matches the wounds that we see on each
of our victims from Hawaii
prior to the attack on Eric Shaw there
was only one recorded cookie cutter
attack in all of Hawaii's history but in
2019 all three victims were bitten by
cookie-cutter sharks in the same stretch
of water
why have these bizarre creatures started
attacking swimmers
a clue emerges from the details of
Eric's attack
there was something else in the water
that night I noticed an amount of
bioluminescence that I had never
witnessed or experienced previously
bioluminescence describes the production
of visible light by a living organism
such as a firefly or certain types of
jellyfish
in the ocean it's most commonly
generated by a type of phytoplankton
Dr Heather Bracken Grissom of Florida
International University investigates
whether this naturally occurring glow
could have played a role in Eric's
attack
since is one of the most beautiful
planet
[Music]
blue light and many organisms including
the cookie cutter are curious and will
come towards the light a shark's Vision
Works differently than a human's they
don't see color instead sharks identify
prey through contrast the differences
between light and dark
that means the light from glowing
phytoplankton May attract them
the problem is that it's not just sea
creatures that can cause disillumination
a lot of bioluminescence is produced by
so if a swimmer is swimming through a
channel it's going to stir up the
bioluminescence and produce a lot of
light
Dr Bracken Grissom demonstrates how this
might work
what I have here is a globe full of
bioluminescent dinoflagellates a
dinoflagellate is a single cell organism
that's very common in the Plankton
environment so what I'm going to
demonstrate is what this bioluminescence
might look like as swimmers are moving
through the water
here we're going to be swirling the
globe with the bioluminescent
dinoflagellates in there
so it is possible that the motion of the
swimmers was stimulating bioluminescence
in the water and it's also possible that
the cookie cutters was drawn to that
bioluminescence
but something doesn't quite fit
swimmers have been crossing the Molokai
channel for years and bioluminescence
has always been present yet the attacks
are a recent phenomenon
bioluminescence can't be the cause of
the spike
the case is off to an Illuminating start
but the Quest for Clues will soon lead
investigators into the darkest depths of
the ocean
a detail from the first ever cookie
cutter attack yields a disturbing clue
I grew up on Oahu most of my life I've
lived on Maui
all of my life I've been involved with
water sports Mike Spalding is a long
distance swimmer who lives in Hawaii
in 2009 he's attempting to cross the
allenui haha Channel between the big
island and Maui
but something is waiting for Mike in the
depths of the ocean
we strategically left at three o'clock
in the afternoon knowing that we would
be swimming through the night
we started off in beautiful water in
five hours I was 10 miles offshore at
first the 30 mile swim seems to be going
to plan I was making good time the
current was helpful when I laid out the
program for the swim I told the captain
zero lights lights attract fish sharks
are attracted to fish zero lights
got dark about 7 45 he was having
difficult seeing me and he turned his
lights on so he could spot me
thinking that it'd be better to have the
lights on even if it's going to attract
bait than losing me out there in the
Blue Waters
but Mike and his crew aren't the only
ones in the water
then all of a sudden I got hit by the
squid
and that's when all hell broke loose
I got hit by the first squid and then a
second and then a third
I was terrified that something really
bad was about to happen
all of a sudden had a very sharp pain in
my sternum
Mike doesn't know it but he has just
become the first recorded human victim
of a cookie-cutter shark attack
I grabbed the kayak and I'm struggling
to get into the kayak and my legs were
egg beating and kicking and that's when
I got hit and it felt just like a punch
it was just like a
but I ran my fingers down my leg
and I felt this big divot this hole in
my leg then I started to bleed profusely
from then on it was let's get to the
hospital as quick as possible
about five hours going full speed the
diesel boat to get to Kihei boat ramp
after several surgeries and months of
Rehabilitation Mike makes a full
recovery I'm gonna come back I'm not
gonna let this incident stop me from
from swimming this channel I'm going to
come back one more time
the attack on Mike Spalding occurs 10
years before the spike in attacks in
2019 so what changed in that time to
make cookie cutter sharks so much more
aggressive
Mike thinks he knows the answer there
are a lot of people doing the channel
That year and if they're out there at
night there's going to be more cookie
cutter shark bikes
a surge in the popularity of Channel
swimming could increase the chances of a
human shark interaction
a plausible hypothesis
but does it stand up
Dr Don Kobayashi is a biologist with the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Association who studies the open ocean
ecosystem including sharks when we heard
about three attacks in the early part of
2019 happening within the scope of just
a few months
first thing that came to mind was maybe
there's more swimmers in the water
Dr kobayashi's research finds something
surprising I looked at a website that
documents Channel Crossings in Hawaii
what I found was that with regard to the
channel swimmers it doesn't look like
2019 had more swimmers in the water
there are probably less swimmers in the
water than an average year at least in
that particular Channel
the fact of the matter is that the
number of swimmers who compete and the
number of successful Crossings of the
channel actually doesn't correlate with
the spike in attacks in 2019 which
suggests that there's something else
contributing to this
perhaps there is another reason why the
swimmers are attracting sharks
and it centers around a particular part
of the day
Mike's attack and the three 2019
incidents all happened at night the time
of day when cookie cutter sharks migrate
from the depths up to the surface
cookie cutter shark spend most of their
time in pretty deep water down to depths
of about three thousand feet but each
night they make a migration up towards
the surface in order to follow their
prey this puts them potentially in
Greater contact with people
Dr James Anderson of California State
University Long Beach investigates how
cookie cutter sharks hunt at night so
the question becomes how do these
animals actually find their prey we know
that they have these big eyes which
allow for more light to come in so then
we have to look at the other sensory
organs that can give us Clues as to how
it hunts how it finds its prey so one of
the things we can look at is the lateral
line system
the lateral line runs from the tip of a
shark's snout to its tail and along both
sides of its body it's made up of a
series of fluid-filled canals lined with
tiny receptor cells so water flushes in
runs across those receptor cells and
then that triggers an action potential
that goes back to the brain sending
messages about the directionality of
that water flow came from
sharks use this Keen sense to hunt
once they feel a vibration in the water
they follow it in search of a meal
cookie cutters have a well-developed
lateral line system which allows them to
take water movements generated by
potential Predators or potential prey
could the changes in water pressure made
by a splashing swimmer be attracting
sharks to the area increasing the
chances of an attack it's absolutely
possible that the movements of the
swimmers attracted the attention of the
cookie cutters yes that is primarily
part of what that that are aligned
system on the fish is for
swimmers have been crossing the Molokai
channel for years without incident
for this Theory to stand up something
would have to be different about the
behavior of these particular swimmers I
really don't think that the three
swimmers who got better would have been
splashing any more than any other
swimmer who'd made that swim that year
or any other time
yes it's possible that the animals were
queuing in on vibrations water movement
they generated but I don't believe it's
because they had a particularly bad
swimming style compared to anyone else
in The Quest For answers
investigators are about to uncover a new
clue that could solve the mystery
the thing that really worries me about
coconut sharks is that we have no idea
about their movement so I don't even
know when to be scared
scientists know that cookie cutter
sharks hunt at night and a detail from
Mike's attack offers another clue as to
what they might have been hunting the
cookie cutter shark bite was within
minutes of being bumped by the squid
Dr Kim Holland of the shark Lab at the
University of Hawaii Manoa is at a local
fish auction in search of other victims
of cookie cutter sharks
this is a great place to see how common
cookie cutter shark bites are on all the
different species that are here for sale
on the auction floor
cookie cutter sharks have long been
considered parasites that prey on larger
marine life for their primary food
source
here is a good example of two wounds
right next to each other one circular
one there is quite fresh this is the
scar of an old one so it's a very common
phenomena
so cookie cutter sharks are actually
quite specialized taking plugs of tissue
out of larger animals whether those
animals be a swordfish or a tuna or even
a dolphin but another fish here provides
a crucial piece of evidence so over here
we have a row of mahi mahi and these
live in the top part of the water column
so these are quite shallow but even
these have cookie cutter shark bites on
them like this one right here
this is key because long distance
swimmers swim at the same level where
mahi mahi are found and mahi mahi are
known to prey on squid
a reason for the attack starts to emerge
as a case of mistaken identity well you
can see that a cookie cutter shark
doesn't really care what it takes to
bite out of so if it gets a chance to
get close to a human it would probably
think okay here's a Target
biggest chances
did cookie cutter sharks in the Molokai
Channel mistake Mike and the 2019 Spike
victims for large marine life
Dr Sora Kim at the University of
California Merced researches the diet of
sharks
for the cookie cutter y cutter shark
project we looked at muscle tissue and
liver because they captured different
amounts of time in terms of diet
traditionally we thought that cookie
cutter sharks a large prey and this was
because this is what we could see at the
fish market in June 2021 scientists
including Dr Kim publish a surprising
study overturning the conventional
wisdom about cookie cutter shark diet I
was surprised to find that they were
eating pretty low on the food chain
things like small fish and Squid and
that these larger prey are actually a
much smaller part of their diet
were the cookie cutter sharks drawn to
the area by the presence of squid
bringing them into contact with the
swimmers and triggering the attacks
that these three swimmers were attack
because of these dial vertical migrating
prey so if there were squid present and
the cookie cutter sharks were hoping to
eat that but instead they found a larger
prey than they would have gone after
that
the theory seems to hold water but when
the details of all three attacks are
analyzed a problem emerges
none of the swimmers in 2019 reported
seeing squid in the water
perhaps the cause of the attacks is not
something that attracted the Sharks but
something that was supposed to keep them
away
investigators turned their attention to
the second victim in 2019.
this is the channel where it happens
I haven't been back
several years
Isaiah Mojica is a 25 year old Marathon
swimmer who's completed several major
Channel Crossings
the love for it after training for the
English Channel so in April of 2019 I
had already swam the English Channel and
the Catalina Channel and my goal was to
swim the Molokai Channel just three
weeks after the attack on Eric Shaw
Isaiah is preparing to make his own
Molokai Channel Crossing when I was
getting ready for the swim
and Eric Charles Sharp incident I mean
the shark attacks are really rare and I
didn't think it would happen to me
the goal was to start the swim around 5
30 swim through the nights and then
finish around mid-morning
swim definitely felt like bathtub water
the water seemed very calm
but the calm doesn't last
at Sunset right after the team turned on
navigational lights Isaiah experiences a
strange stinging sensation
after a while I kind of got used to the
the feeling and I realized
this night draws in the crew deploys a
special safety mechanism every 30
seconds the device emits a low voltage
electric pulse in the water which is
designed to keep large sharks away from
the swimmer
but the pulse is strong enough for
Isaiah to feel it as he swims swimming
next to the shark Shield I could feel a
sharp zap like a static electricity's
app except kind of all over your body
around midnight boat captain Ivan
shigaki tosses a thermos with a light
attached to Isaiah signaling it is time
for a feeding break but something else
in the water is also preparing to feed
on Isaiah all of a sudden I felt a sharp
pain in my back
I also heard
I don't think I'll ever forget the sound
of that bite or the or the feeling and I
felt a strong tug on my left shoulder
and I thought that it possibly could
have just been a shark Shield or a
jellyfish kind of zapping me because my
body tensed up I reached back to see
what had happened and I can feel this
deep hole in my back
and that's when I knew that something
was terribly wrong
I started screaming get me out get me
out the boat captain acts swiftly we
turn on the lights and and we looked and
there's a cookie cutter shark swimming
away from him as Isaiah swam away from
the shark he went over to the kayaker
and jumped on the kayak the kayak
flipped and he flipped
the kayaker shouted oh no I see it too
but now I have Isaiah in the water and
the kayaker in the water
the men Scramble for help we're trying
to get Isaiah into the boat I grabbed
onto his swim trunks and literally
yanked him onto the death
and immediately said okay we need you to
lie down here started getting out towels
took a towel and used that to try to
stop the bleeding the captain turns the
boat back towards Oahu
back on Shore Isaiah is rushed by
ambulance to the hospital
when I was hospitalized they cleaned out
the wounds
fortunately there was no skin graft but
what they did was they essentially sewed
up each layer of muscle and fat and skin
it is a full six weeks before Isaiah
recovers
it's just like a straight scar right
here on the left shoulder
but the impact of the terrifying attack
leaves a lasting impression
haven't tried any Channel swim since the
incident I think it'll be a few years
from now before I step back into the
Molokai Channel
Isaiah is the second of three swimmers
to be attacked in the Molokai channel in
2019.
all of them by cookie cutter sharks
the cause of this rare surge in shark
attacks is a total mystery
but a detail from Isaiah's swim offers a
possible lead
a unique piece of equipment placed in
the water alongside Isaiah
I went with the shark Shield because I
thought that the Extra Protection would
be helpful on the swim
Hawaii's waters are home to more than 40
species of shark posing potential
threats to swimmers
many long-distance swimmers deploy shark
shields in an attempt to keep the
Predators at Bay
and while these anti-shark devices are
thought to repel larger sharks like
Bulls tigers and great whites cookie
cutter sharks are different one of the
things that is curious about cooking
Cutters is that they do seem to be
attracted to unusual electrical Fields
so cookie cutters have been known to
bite undersea cables and damage them and
even bite through them they've been
known to attack the sonar equipment on
submarines to the point that they had to
start developing ways to protect the
Telemetry devices for the sonar so the
cookie cutters wouldn't damage them
this surprising fact leads Isaiah to an
unconventional Theory
it's possible that electric truck
deterrence May attract cookie cutter
sharks could a shark deterrent actually
have the opposite effect so they do seem
to have an attraction to unusual
electrical fields that other animals
aren't
could this compelling detail be the
missing piece to the puzzle
so of the three Marathon swimmers that
made the Molokai Crossing two of them
were using Shark deterrent devices at
the time whereas one was not and yet
still got bitten so it points to the
shark deterrent device has not been the
singular cause of any of those swimmers
being bitten
knowing shark deterrents are not the
primary cause
investigators focus on another attack in
2019 that may hold vital Clues
Matt Buckman is a boat captain escorting
a Brazilian Channel swimmer from Oahu to
Hawaii
swimmer's name is aderball trailer
Oliveira
it's very
cool and confident
we started about 4 30 in the afternoon
he was set at such a great Pace he was
on time to make a record and after about
six hours we had covered 18 miles but
this swim is about to set a very
different record
Matt watches Adderall unexpectedly slow
down and he screamed out loud fish fish
the support kayak comes in for a closer
look
that's where the cookie cutter shark
came up and grabbed him
and I saw him like boom jumped up by the
front of the kayak real quick and I just
jammed it in reverse right towards them
to get him on the boat as quickly as
possible with the injured swimmer on
board the severity of the situation
becomes apparent as soon as I saw the
wound I knew it was a cookie cutter
shark there was quite a bit of Bud and
we tourniquated him up and we just
punched him and right when we pulled up
the ambulance pulled up at the same time
Adder ball is treated for his injuries
and eventually makes a full recovery
he is the third swimmer to be attacked
by cookie cutter sharks in the Molokai
channel in just over four months
this unprecedented Spike leaves locals
and scientists desperate for answers
what's going on is the moon lining up is
it a phase that is it an explosion in
population nobody really knew
most of what we know about cookie cutter
sharks particularly their distribution
around the world actually comes from
forensic evidence from the bites that
they leave on their prey items now in
addition to that cookie cutter shark
wounds are actually also used to help
understand human fatalities that have
happened in the ocean particularly to
understand how long those bodies have
been in the water
worldwide investigators wonder why
living humans have only recently come
under attack
is it possible the 2019 Spike was caused
by a single flesh hungry cookie cutter
shark
what scientists know is that
interactions between humans and
cookie-cutter sharks are extremely rare
could the cause of the attacks be the
work of a single Rogue shark that has
developed a taste for human flesh
the idea of a rogue shark is that
there's one shark that for some reason
or another has attacked multiple humans
and there's very very limited evidence
for this throughout history but the fact
of the matter is that there are some
cases in which this has occurred it's
thought that in 1919 a Spate of fatal
shock attacks along the New Jersey Shore
was the work of a single Rogue bull
shark
100 years later and halfway across the
world is the same thing happening in
Hawaii
now it's been suggested that the cookie
cutter shark attacks on humans in the
Molokai channel in 2019 could have
involved a rogue cookie cutter sharks
the answer lies in the bite marks left
on the swimmers who were attacked these
are all classic cookie cutter shark
wounds all of them have this circular
form to them now when we look at all of
these wounds we see a lot of similarity
because all of these have those telltale
signs of a cookie cutter shark having
been involved in the attack now some of
these attacks even happened in a pretty
close proximity similar times to each
other distinct bite patterns could be
the very clue investigators have been
waiting for in addition to comparing
bite wounds from the 2019 survivors Dr
Huber also analyzes the bite wounds of
the first ever Hawaii cookie cutter
attack that of Mike Spalding while Mike
and Isaiah's attacks appear to have come
from cookie cutter sharks that were a
very similar size potentially the same
shark
outer balls attack was definitely from a
smaller shark so there's no way that the
same shark could have been responsible
for each of these attacks
it's highly unlikely that there was a
single cookie cutter shark attacking
swimmers in 2019.
to unlock the secrets of this elusive
creature investigators turned to someone
who has encountered them on many
occasions it's extremely rare to
actually see a cookie cutter shark first
time I saw a cookie cutter shark I
didn't realize I was looking at a Shark
cookie cutter sharks are by far the
weirdest looking shark I've ever seen
Josh lambus is an award-winning
photographer specializing in night Dives
known as Black Water Dives
in 2008 he became the first person known
to capture a living cookie-cutter shark
on video
you know as far as I knew it was an
elusive shark that no one got to see and
that it wasn't until we started black
water diving with some regularity that
we we actually got to see him
Josh believes a clue could lie in a key
aspect of cookie cutter shark behavior
one that is part of a much larger
natural phenomenon that occurs in the
ocean every single night
to demonstrate he heads towards the side
of the 2019 attacks
the Molokai Channel
the movement of sea creatures from deep
water to the surface is called vertical
dial migration this migration that we're
seeing each night during a black water
dive is actually the largest migration
on the planet the animals we come across
out there are completely out of this
world I sometimes think that if we
somehow came across an alien species we
wouldn't even know that it was an alien
species
just like the 2019 attacks all of Josh's
cookie cutter shark encounters occurred
at night and near the surface
foreign
these sharks swim up from the deaths
also be the reason for the spike in
attacks on humans cookie cutter sharks
spend most of their time in pretty deep
water down to depths of about three
thousand feet but each night they make a
migration up towards the surface in
order to follow their prey and as they
work their way up towards the surface
this puts them potentially in Greater
contact with people
while the presence of cookie cutter
sharks near the surface at night is
clearly a factor in the attacks it
cannot explain why the spike occurred
there must be something else
in 2019 the scientific community in
Hawaii witnessed another unusual Marine
phenomenon one that could unlock the
secret to the mystery once and for all
in 2019 when the people got attacked by
the cookie cutter sharks we started
seeing a lot of these very unusual deep
water fish which no one has seen in
Hawaii coming up into shallow water by
the hundreds
these fish are called knife jaw fish
knife jaw fish are found deep below the
ocean's surface
they are named after a strange
characteristic of their teeth which fuse
together to form a razor-sharp beak
in ancient Hawaiian history there is no
record of knife jaw fish in the Hawaiian
Islands turns out that these knife jaw
fish live in the deep water Canyons
offshore Hawaii 500 feet all the way
down to about 2 000 feet deep could the
surfacing of the rarely seen knife jaw
fish in 2019 provide the evidence needed
to solve the case
marine biologist Terry Lilly believes
there's a connection between the
sightings of the knife jaw fish and the
cookie cutter shark attacks
for over 50 years now it has been well
known by the scientific community and
the U.S military that sonar coming off
of submarines underwater affects the
behavior of our whales dolphins sea
turtles fish and sharks
could a change in deep water military
exercises answer the rare cookie cutter
and human Clash cookie cutter sharks do
move up and down they do this for a
variety of reasons it could be to find
food to avoid predation it could be a
lot of things but most things that are
mobile can and will find their comfort
zone of preferred habitat
now that the military has told us that
they moved this activity none of these
problems currently exist
so I think that shows us that this
underwater submarine activity really did
have an effect on our marine life in
this 2019 time frame
was the alleged increase in Deepwater
military activity enough to explain the
2019 attacks
there's been military activity Navy
activity in Hawaii for decades it's a
very important base for the Navy so I
don't think there's been any change in
the naval or other kinds of activity it
could account for a putative spike in
cookie cutter shark bites
deep water military activity in the
channel does not explain the spike
there is one critical clue still to
explore
the water itself
before 2019 there was only one recorded
cookie cutter attack in Hawaiian Waters
but that year there were three vicious
attacks
Something In The Water must have changed
Dr Don Kobayashi and his team have
identified a key difference in the
marine environment that occurred in
2019. once we heard about the 2019 Spike
my colleague Dr Ryan rikazewski and
myself started to explore the
oceanography of the channel region
particularly with respect to Sea surface
temperature 2019 was a very very odd
Year and that it started out cooler than
usual ended up much warmer than usual so
it wasn't a cool year or warm year per
se but it was a little bit of both
to their surprise the researchers found
what is referred to in the scientific
Community as an anomaly by anomalous sea
surface temperature we mean it fell
outside the range of the 10th or 90th
percentile respectively for cooler or
warmer sea surface temperatures so we're
still trying to figure out what causes
that and it's probably related to this
large gyre a gyre is a system of
rotational currents Hawaii resides in
the North Pacific gyre which moves
clockwise and is formed by four ocean
currents the North Pacific the
California the north equatorial and the
Kuroshio
the temperature of the ocean will depend
on the speed of that gyre and how fast
that water is moving around in that very
very large wheel which was known to be
spinning a little bit slower that year
so this had pronounced effects on the
oceanography around the Hawaiian Islands
most of the jars slow rotational speed
water temperatures around Hawaii in 2019
started off colder but heated up to the
second highest surface temperatures on
record by mid-summer
right around the time of the last cookie
cutter attacks of that year
but how would these warmer temperatures
affect the behavior of sharks we have
some hypotheses that perhaps a change in
the vertical distribution of the cookie
cutter sharks might put it in that
overlap region with a human swimmer near
the surface of the ocean they could also
be changes in the cookie cutter sharks
Predator prey Dynamics like perhaps it's
hungrier or the food has changed its
location but given that the oceanography
seems to have changed there's probably
something going on with the cookie
cutter shark behavior that brings it
more into contact with humans in that
year
Dan Huber believes this plays into a key
predatory characteristic of many Marine
creatures including sharks this feeds
into a physiological process called hunt
warm rest cool
sharks will move into warmer Waters in
order to hunt because in those warmer
Waters they'll have a higher metabolic
rate and their muscles will perform at a
higher level
but once they get their food in those
warm Waters they Retreat into colder
Waters and when they do so their
metabolic rate is going to go down which
means that the meal that they just got
is actually going to last longer
so because the water is off the coast of
Hawaii we're warmer than normal during
the summer of 2019
this could have resulted in more cookie
cutter sharks more actively feeding in
those shallow Waters and potentially
being the contributing factor that
explains the spike in 2019.
an unusual swing from cooler to
record-breaking warmer Waters in The
Molokai channel is likely the answer to
the 2019 Spike
[Music]
thank you